And so they fought, now closing, now breaking. What shall Benkei do? For when he thinks that he has conquered, with his little sword, the boy thrusts the blow aside. Again and again, Benke strikes. Again and again, his blows are parrid. Till at last even he, mighty Benkei, can do battle no longer. So that's a scene from the Japanese no play, if you like, no theatre.
于是他们打了起来，时而近身，时而分开。弁庆该怎么办呢？因为当他以为自己已经胜券在握时，那个少年用他的小剑拨开了攻击。弁庆一次又一次地挥剑，又一次又一次地被格挡。直到最后，连这位强大的弁庆也无法再战。这就是日本能剧，或者说能剧剧场中的一个场景。
It's called Benkei on the bridge, and it was written in the 15th century. And it describes perhaps the most celebrated fight in the entire history of the samurai. So at the British Museum right now, there are three different illustrations of this tremendous encounter. Tom, you love the story of Benke-Kin-the-Bridge, don't you? I do. Who doesn't love the most famous fight in samurai history? Surely it's your favourite, too. It's certainly in the top five of samurai fights, yeah.
它被称为《桥上的弁庆》，写于15世纪。它描述的可能是武士历史上最著名的一场战斗。所以在大英博物馆现在就有三幅关于这场惊人对决的插画。汤姆，你很喜欢“桥上的弁庆”这个故事，对吧？是的。谁会不喜欢武士历史上最著名的战斗呢？这肯定也是你的最爱吧。确实是武士战斗前五名之一，没错。
And it's famous because it's endlessly retold and it's endlessly illustrated. and the backdrop to it is is that Benke is a lawless warrior monk. Always the most dangerous kind of warrior monk. He is built like a rugby player. He's got bloodshot eyes. He wears black armor. And he holds seven weapons. So he has a sword.
它之所以出名，是因为它被不断地重述和描绘。故事的背景是弁庆是一个无法无天的僧兵。这向来是最危险的那种僧兵。他长得像个橄榄球运动员，眼睛布满血丝，穿着黑色盔甲，带着七种武器。他有一把剑。
He has a staff. He has an axe. He has a sickle. He has a mallet. He has a saw and a rake. He's not holding them all at the same time, presumably. No, he's not holding them all the time. And I like the fact he has a sore and a rake.
他有一根棍子，一把斧头，一把镰刀，一把木槌，一把锯子和一把耙子。他大概不是同时拿着所有这些东西。不，他不是一直拿着它们。我喜欢他有锯子和耙子这一点。
So he can do a spot of gar. gardening or something if he's... Yeah, yeah. Those sort of Zen gardens of a lot of gravel. Yes. He'd be raking his Zen garden. He's ready and prepared for anything. He said he's a lawless warrior monk.
所以如果他想的话，他可以做点园艺之类的……是的，是的。那些有很多碎石的禅宗花园。没错，他会耙他的禅宗花园。他随时准备好应对任何事情。他说他是一个无法无天的僧兵。
And as lawless warrior monks often do, he vows to rob a thousand men of their swords. And so he stands on a bridge in Kyoto. The story goes. And every samurai who tries to cross it, Benke fights him. And he is so invincible that he ends up with 999 swords. So he's got one sword to go to make the thousand.
正如无法无天的僧兵常做的那样，他发誓要抢走一千个人的剑。故事说，他就站在京都的一座桥上。每一个试图过桥的武士，弁庆都会与他战斗。他战无不胜，最终收集了999把剑。所以他只差一把剑就凑齐一千把了。
And the scene which you narrated, this is him trying to get his thousandth sword. And his opponent is a very slight, elegant youth wearing a woman's cloak who'd been playing the flute as he approached the bridge. So, you know, kind of faint hint of the girly about it, I guess. Yeah, but maybe lulling him into a full sense of security, is he? Well, maybe, because he turns out to be so formidable an opponent that Benkei ends up defeated. Oh, what? And we're told in the no play, he can do battle no longer. And he submits to his opponent.
而你刚才讲述的那个场景，就是他试图夺取第一千把剑的时候。他的对手是一个非常瘦小、优雅的少年，穿着女人的斗篷，在接近桥时一直在吹笛子。所以，你知道，我想这带有一点点女性化的暗示。是的，但也许是在让他放松警惕？嗯，也许吧，因为事实证明他是一个如此强大的对手，以至于弁庆最终被打败了。哦，什么？能剧中说，他无法再战，于是向对手投降了。
And from this point on, he is the victor's loyal follower. So he becomes his samurai. That's what samurai means, retainer. And who is this person who's defeated him? Well, he is a guy called Minamoto no Yosh. Chitsune and we actually met him in our previous episode, in which listeners may remember we were describing the outbreak of the great war between the Tyra clan and the Minamoto clan. So we're in 12th century Japan, so medieval Japan, the emperors have become slightly sort of
从这一刻起，他成了胜利者的忠实追随者。所以他成了他的武士。这就是武士的意思，即家臣。那么这个打败他的人是谁呢？嗯，他是一个叫源义经的人，我们在上一集里其实提到过他，听众可能还记得我们当时在描述平氏家族和源氏家族之间爆发的大战。所以我们现在是在12世纪的日本，也就是中世纪的日本，天皇已经变得有点……
kind of ciphers almost. Yeah, ciphers, almost like puppet figures. And these two clans loosely related to the imperial family, sort of, semi-detached from the imperial family, what are they called the Tyra and the Minamoto? They are fighting for supremacy. And remind me, which is the one that is strongest in the West in the Kansai area? So the Tyra have control over Kyoto, the Great Imperial Capital. They have the Imperial family under their thumb.
几乎成了傀儡。是的，傀儡，几乎就像木偶一样。这两个与皇室有松散联系、某种程度上与皇室半脱离的家族，他们叫什么来着，平氏和源氏？他们正在争夺霸权。提醒我一下，哪一个在西部关西地区最强大？平氏控制着京都，即伟大的帝国首都。他们把皇室掌握在自己手中。
And they had expelled the Minamoto pretty much from the kind of civilized center of Japan. And they have all been dispersed to the barbarous northeastern stretches of Japan. Yes. Yoshitsune is a member of this clan. So hence Minamoto no Yoshitsunei. And so this is the background for the fleeting appearance, as we said, of Yashitsune in our previous episode. Because he was the baby who had been folded in the cloak of his mother, the concubine, Tokiwa, as she attempted to escape Kyoto in a snowstorm. And Tokuwa had become the concubine of Kiyomori, who was the most powerful man in Japan, the leader of the Tyra clan.
他们几乎把源氏从日本所谓的文明中心驱逐了出去。他们都被分散到了日本野蛮的东北地区。是的。义经是这个家族的一员。所以叫源义经。这就是我们上一集提到义经短暂出现时的背景。因为他就是那个被他的母亲，也就是妾室常盘御前，裹在斗篷里试图在暴风雪中逃离京都的婴儿。常盘御前后来成了平清盛的妾室，而平清盛是当时日本最有权势的人，平氏家族的首领。
and so therefore the inveterate enemy of the rival Minamoto clan. And Yoshitsune's father, Yoshitomo, had been the head of the Minamoto. And Yoshitomo had been killed in his bath. He'd been trying to get away, ended up murdered by a supposed friend. Kiamori had only spared Yoshitsune out of affection for his mother, because Tokua ends up as Kiamori's concubine. And so Yoshitsune had been brought up in complete ignorance of his father. his identity. He did not know that he was the son of this great Minamoto Lord. He had no idea about
因此，他也是敌对的源氏家族的死敌。义经的父亲源义朝曾是源氏的首领。义朝在洗澡时被杀。他当时试图逃跑，结果被一个所谓的朋友谋杀。清盛只是出于对常盘御前的喜爱才饶了义经一命，因为常盘御前最终成了清盛的妾室。所以义经是在完全不知道自己父亲身份的情况下长大的。他不知道自己是这位伟大的源氏领主的儿子。他对此一无所知。
that. And then at the age of six, he gets packed off by Kiamori to a monastery north of Kyoto on the slopes of Mount Karama, great mountain north of Kyoto. And Kiamori's plan is that Shitsune will grow up in harmless and ignorant seclusion as a monk. He doesn't know who his father is, doesn't know that he's in Minamoto, and he's a monk. So therefore, hopefully he's not going to grow up to become a samurai. But clearly, he's now out and about fighting warrior monks on a bridge. You know, that plan hasn't worked out. So, you know, basically the big question is, what's been going on in his life?
然后在他六岁时，他被清盛送到了京都以北鞍马山山坡上的一座寺院里。清盛的计划是让义经作为一个僧侣，在无害且无知的隐居生活中长大。他不知道自己的父亲是谁，不知道自己是源氏，他只是个僧侣。所以希望他长大后不会成为一名武士。但显然，他现在已经在桥上和僧兵打架了。你知道，那个计划并没有奏效。所以，基本上最大的问题是，他的生活中到底发生了什么？
How has he ended up this great warrior? Well, this is a great samurai tale, isn't it? So the story of his youth and how he basically grows up to become himself. And this is a story that evolved over the course of medieval Japanese history. People told it and retold it and elaborated on it, right? Yeah. And it becomes the best beloved of all the samurai tales. almost the kind of the archetypal samurai tale. And it tells how he's this young boy in his monastery
他是怎么成为这个伟大的武士的？嗯，这是一个伟大的武士故事，不是吗？关于他的少年时代以及他如何成长为现在的他。这是一个在中世纪日本历史进程中不断演变的故事。人们讲述它、重述它并对其进行润色，对吧？是的。它成为了所有武士故事中最受喜爱的一个，几乎成了武士故事的原型。它讲述了他如何在寺院里还是个小男孩。
and then a servant who is loyal to his father's memory reveals to him his true identity. And Shitsune then goes up onto the side of the mountain of Mount Karama and he meets the great Tengu, who is the spirit lord of the mountain. And very fortunately for Shitsune, the greatest teacher of martial arts anywhere in the cosmos. And the great. Tengu instructs Yashitzine in swordsmanship. So in a sense, he is Yoda to Yishitsune's Luke. Or Merlin to his Arthur, surely. Yes. Yes. I mean, there is something archetypal about this story. There's no question about it. And the great Tengu then leads Yashitschinae to a palace that is deep within the mountains. So embedded within the rock. And here he meets with his father, his dead father, the guy who had been killed in the bath. Yoshitomo and Yoshitomo who's been reborn as a Buddha. And Yoshitomo, I mean, he's not kind of peace and love.
然后一个忠于他父亲记忆的仆人向他揭示了他的真实身份。义经随后登上了鞍马山的山腰，遇到了伟大的天狗，也就是山中的灵主。对义经来说非常幸运的是，天狗是宇宙中最伟大的武术老师。伟大的天狗教导了义经剑术。所以从某种意义上说，他是义经的尤达大师。或者肯定是他的梅林。是的，是的。我的意思是，这个故事确实有一些原型特征。毫无疑问。伟大的天狗随后将义经带到了深山中的一座宫殿。嵌入岩石之中。在这里，他见到了他的父亲，他死去的父亲，那个在洗澡时被杀的人，源义朝。而源义朝，他已经转世为佛。我的意思是，源义朝并不是那种爱好和平与爱的人。
He's very much the go out and kill all my enemies, kill all the Tyra, have vengeance for the, you know, for my overthrow. And Yoshitomo tells his son, you are going to grow up and you are going to become the greatest of all the samurai. So you mentioned King Arthur. I mean, there's definitely a kind of King Arthur dimension there. the young boy who doesn't know his father who gets adopted by a kind of great wizard and is kind of given, you know, swords and all this kind of thing. But if you throw in the battle with Benkei on the bridge, which follow, you know, he leaves the monastery and he goes out to find his fortune in the world and he runs into Benkei. There is also a very strong element there of Robin Hood, because I'm sure that people will be reminded of Robin Hood meeting with Frye Tuck. And I know that, you know, Frye Tuck is a friar, not a monk.
他非常主张出去杀光我的敌人，杀光平氏，为我的覆灭复仇。源义朝告诉他的儿子，你长大后将成为所有武士中最伟大的一位。所以你提到了亚瑟王。我的意思是，那里肯定有一种亚瑟王式的维度。那个不知道自己父亲是谁的小男孩，被一位伟大的巫师收养，并被赋予了剑和所有这些东西。但如果你加上后来在桥上与弁庆的战斗，他离开寺院去寻找自己的命运，然后遇到了弁庆。这里也有非常强烈的罗宾汉元素，因为我相信人们会想起罗宾汉与塔克修士的相遇。我知道，塔克修士是修士，不是僧侣。
but basically, you know, pretty much the same thing. It is kind of mad that islands at the opposite end of Eurasia should both have these 12th century folk heroes who fight a kind of monk-like figure on a bridge. But Yoshitsune is a genuine historical figure. And Robin Hood and King Arthur and indeed Luke Skywalker are arguably not. Arguably. There must be some kernel of historical truth behind the stories of Yusitzunay. I mean, more than a colonel, he is a very, very significant historical figure. And in fact,
但基本上，差不多是一回事。欧亚大陆两端的岛屿竟然都有这些12世纪的民间英雄，在桥上与某种僧侣式的人物战斗，这真是太疯狂了。但义经是一个真实的历史人物。而罗宾汉、亚瑟王，甚至卢克·天行者，可以说都不是。可以说。义经的故事背后一定有一些历史真相的内核。我的意思是，不仅仅是内核，他是一个非常、非常重要的历史人物。事实上，
he comes to rank as one of the greatest generals in the whole of Japanese history. And although lots of the stories that are told about him, and particularly about his youth, are obviously fantastical, they are hinting at aspects of his story that I think are genuinely mysterious. And they have evolved to try and explain things that admirers of Ishizs of Yeshizanay once he'd become this great general. They wanted to know where exactly he'd come from and there were clearly all kinds of puzzles around it. So, you know, he clearly was spared as a baby, despite being Yoshitomo's son. And presumably then, the story of him being sent to the monastery is true. I mean, that does kind of make sense. But if he sent to the monastery, then at some point he must have learned swordsmanship.
他被列为日本历史上最伟大的将军之一。虽然关于他的许多故事，特别是关于他少年时代的故事，显然是虚构的，但它们暗示了他故事中我认为确实神秘的方面。它们经过演变，试图解释那些在义经成为伟大将军后崇拜他的人们心中的疑问。他们想知道他到底是从哪里来的，显然围绕着这一点有各种各样的谜团。所以，他显然作为一个婴儿被饶了一命，尽管他是源义朝的儿子。大概关于他被送往寺院的故事是真的。我的意思是，这确实说得通。但如果他被送往寺院，那么在某个时候他一定学会了剑术。
And if not with the great Tengu, then from someone else. And as a youth, we know that he definitely did attract a band of formidable samurai. and maybe Benkei, this warrior monk, was one of them. Hold on. Benkei definitely existed. There are early sources by which we mean kind of 60, 70 years after the events are supposed to have happened that do describe a warrior monk called Benkei in Yoshitsune's train. The only issue being that he is described as being very thin and ascetic and not built like a rugby player.
如果不是跟伟大的天狗学的，那就是跟别人学的。作为少年，我们知道他确实吸引了一群强大的武士。也许弁庆这个僧兵就是其中之一。等等。弁庆确实存在。我们指的是在事件发生后约60、70年的早期文献中，确实描述了义经麾下有一位叫弁庆的僧兵。唯一的问题是，他被描述为非常瘦弱、苦行，而不是长得像个橄榄球运动员。
But you could see perhaps, you know, it's a better story if he becomes this kind of great hulking monster in black armor. Yeah, yeah. I mean, essentially, we don't really know anything about his youth. He's a good swordsman. He has this band of samurai. He has discovered who his father is. And it's only when Yoshitsune is 20, so this is in the year 1180, that at last we get real
但你可以看出，如果他变成这种穿着黑色盔甲的庞然大物，故事会更好。是的，是的。我的意思是，本质上，我们对他的少年时代一无所知。他是个优秀的剑客。他有这群武士。他发现了自己的父亲是谁。直到义经20岁，也就是1180年，我们才终于得到了真正的
historical certainty, because this is the year when he emerges from this kind of obscurity that he's been veiled throughout his youth to join his half-brother, Yoritomo. who is now the head of the Minamoto clan. And this is a very dramatic moment because the two half-brothers have never met before. And it happens in the most iconic place possibly in the whole of Japan in the shadow of Mount Fuji, where Yoritomo is standing guard. And the reason that he is standing guard is because by this point, the Taira, led by Kiomori and the Minamoto, led by Yorotomo, are now at war.
历史确定性，因为这一年他从整个少年时期笼罩着他的那种默默无闻中走出来，加入了他的同父异母兄弟源赖朝。赖朝现在是源氏家族的首领。这是一个非常戏剧性的时刻，因为这两个同父异母的兄弟以前从未见过面。它发生在整个日本可能最具标志性的地方，富士山的阴影下，赖朝正在那里守卫。他之所以守卫，是因为到这个时候，由清盛领导的平氏和由赖朝领导的源氏已经处于战争状态。
All right. Well, let's pull the camera back and let's have a look at the island of Japan and see what the states are players. So let's start with the Taewa. They appear to be in the ascendant, don't they? You already said that they control Kyoto, which is the imperial capital. They control the emperor who is a puppet or a cipher, who is two years old and he is called Antoku. And he is the grandson of Kiomori. Right.
好吧。让我们把镜头拉远，看看日本列岛，看看局势如何。让我们从平氏开始。他们似乎处于上升期，不是吗？你已经说过他们控制了京都，即帝国首都。他们控制着一个傀儡或傀儡皇帝，他两岁，名叫安德天皇。他是清盛的孙子。没错。
And they also control the plane, the Kansai, on which Kyoto stands. So if you think of Japan, archipelago, the single biggest island in the middle is Honshu, and they control the west of Honshu, right? Yes, and also the inland sea, which kind of lies between western Honshu and the two islands south of it, Shikoku and Kusu. So the Taira basically rule the waves. Right. They're effectively the only naval power in Japan.
他们还控制着京都所在的关西平原。所以如果你想到日本，这个群岛，中间最大的岛屿是本州岛，他们控制着本州岛的西部，对吧？是的，还有濑户内海，它位于本州岛西部和南部的两个岛屿四国和九州之间。所以平氏基本上统治着海洋。没错。他们实际上是日本唯一的海洋力量。
And then what about their rivals, the Minamoto? So as I recall from last time, their heartland was around, was the other. The other great plain of Honshu, which is what's it called the Kanto, and that surrounds what's now Tokyo, which doesn't exist at this point. Yes, the Minamoto capital is a place called Kamakura, which is a port just west of what will come to be called Tokyo Bay. Right. And from Kamakura, Yoritomo is able to command the great plain of Kanto and all the kind of the mountainous reaches of eastern Honshu, which is the traditional home of the samurai. Yoritomo himself, so the head of the Minamoto, the elder half-brother of Yashitsunei, is not a natural warrior, but he is a brilliant war leader. He's very ruthlessly pragmatic, very cold-hearted in his hunger for power. He's prepared to elbow anyone aside. But he's also very, very charismatic and commanding. And he has spent 20 years in exile. So Kiyomori, had spared his life when he was just a boy, had sent him off into exile, and he spent 20 years
那么他们的竞争对手源氏呢？据我上次回忆，他们的大本营是在本州岛的另一个大平原，叫什么来着，关东，它环绕着现在的东京，当时还没有东京。是的，源氏的首都叫镰仓，是一个港口，就在后来被称为东京湾的西边。没错。从镰仓，赖朝能够指挥关东大平原和本州岛东部所有那些山区，那是武士的传统家园。赖朝本人，也就是源氏的首领，义经的同父异母哥哥，不是天生的战士，但他是一位出色的战争领袖。他非常冷酷务实，对权力的渴望非常冷血。他准备把任何人挤开。但他也非常、非常有魅力和统率力。他流亡了20年。所以清盛在他还是个孩子时饶了他一命，把他流放了，他度过了20年
biding his time. He completely has the virtues of patience, and he understands the importance of waiting for the perfect moment to strike. And in that, he's very different to your Shitsune, whose great qualities are decisiveness and speed and aggression. And, you know, he's very different. And Yoritomo, when he meets this kind of young half-brother who he'd never met before, he very quickly comes to appreciate these qualities, to appreciate that his younger half-brother is potentially the great warrior, the great general that Yoritomo is, you know, is self-aware enough to realize that he will never be. And so he starts to trust him with all kinds of military responsibilities, even though he's still very, very young.
等待时机。他完全具备耐心的美德，并且明白等待完美时机出击的重要性。在这方面，他与义经非常不同，义经的伟大品质是果断、速度和侵略性。而且，你知道，他非常不同。赖朝在见到这个他从未谋面的年轻同父异母弟弟时，很快就欣赏到了这些品质，意识到他的弟弟可能就是赖朝自己——他有足够的自知之明意识到自己永远无法成为——那种伟大的战士、伟大的将军。所以他开始把各种军事责任交给他，尽管他还非常、非常年轻。
Right. But at first, they don't actually. launch a great war of aggression, do they? Because Yoritomo, his priority is to consolidate his base because he knows that the Taira won't attack him. Why won't they attack him the Tira when they control the waves and stuff? Well, they'd made an attempt, and we described it in the previous episode, they embarrassed themselves by running away from a flock of geese that kind of ran into them. And so Yoritomo has been able to kind of control the road that links Kyoto with Kanto, and he knows that the Tyra are not strong enough to kind of force that. So there's a bit of a kind of deadlock. And the other key event that has happened, which plays to the Minamoto's
没错。但起初，他们并没有真正发动一场大规模的侵略战争，对吧？因为赖朝的首要任务是巩固他的基地，因为他知道平氏不会攻击他。为什么平氏在控制海洋等力量的情况下不攻击他？嗯，他们尝试过，我们在上一集描述过，他们因为被一群撞向他们的大雁吓跑而让自己丢了脸。所以赖朝能够控制连接京都和关东的道路，他知道平氏没有足够的力量强行通过。所以出现了一种僵局。而发生的另一个关键事件，对源氏有利的是
advantage, is the fact that in March 1181, Kiamori had died, supposedly, if the hottest temperature in world history. And he had been a brilliant strategist, a brilliant strategist, whom the Tyra basically find impossible to replace. Right. But then, naturally, disaster or what you might seem a natural disaster. So we have plague and famine, don't we? So the four horsemen of the apocalypse, or however many horsemen there are, we're beginning to rear their heads. So what's the story here? The famine is first and then the plague or vice versa? Yeah, it's the famine first. And of course, it's caused by war because it disrupts the food supplies. So the famine had begun in the very early months of the war and its grip titans and titans and the plague then
事实上，在1181年3月，清盛去世了，据说是死于世界历史上最高的气温。他是一位杰出的战略家，一位平氏基本上发现无法取代的杰出战略家。没错。但随后，自然灾害或你可能认为是自然灾害的事情发生了。所以我们有了瘟疫和饥荒，对吧？所以天启四骑士，或者无论有多少骑士，开始抬头了。那么这里的故事是什么？是先有饥荒还是先有瘟疫，还是反过来？是的，先是饥荒。当然，这是由战争引起的，因为它破坏了粮食供应。所以饥荒在战争的最初几个月就开始了，它的控制力越来越紧，而瘟疫随后
follows in the wake of it. And in Kyoto, bodies start to pile up along the riverbanks, in the streets, terrible scenes. And there is famine too in Canto. But because the plane there is larger and more fertile than Canzai, the plane that surrounds Kyoto, there is more food. You know, this is a tremendous opportunity for Yoritomo because he's able very ostentatiously to muster reserves from his kind of granaries and his kind of rice depots. and send it to help people in the provinces around Kyoto. And the Tyra are desperate to keep Kyoto fed. And so they have been stripping these same provinces that surround Kyoto
紧随其后。在京都，尸体开始在河岸边、街道上堆积，场面惨不忍睹。关东也有饥荒。但因为那里的平原比关西，也就是环绕京都的平原更大、更肥沃，所以有更多的食物。你知道，这对赖朝来说是一个巨大的机会，因为他能够非常显眼地从他的粮仓和米库中调集储备，并派人去帮助京都周边省份的人们。平氏急于让京都吃饱。所以他们一直在剥削环绕京都的这些省份
and giving it to the people in the capital. And so the consequence is that the people around Kyoto are now starting to look to Yorotomo rather than to the Tyra as the guy who is going to give them their food and keep them fed. Famine diplomacy. Yeah. And so Yoritomo's prestige soors and Toro's. Hira prestige is very badly damaged. So we get to 1183 and now Yorotomo is ready to effectively reignite the war.
并把粮食给首都的人民。结果就是，京都周边的人们现在开始转向赖朝，而不是平氏，认为他是那个会给他们粮食并让他们吃饱的人。饥荒外交。是的。所以赖朝的声望飙升，而平氏的声望受到了严重损害。所以我们到了1183年，现在赖朝准备有效地重新点燃战争。
And he's basically going to get his brother, you know, trained in a monastery or wherever trained by Yoda to do this for him, right? Because his brother is clearly the more competent commander. But then there's a twist. Dominic, there is indeed a twist because spring 1183, the war does. resume, the Tyra and the Minamoto start to clash again directly. It does see the Tyra launch a full-scale assault on the Minamoto Heartlands. And it does indeed see a very charismatic, a very able, a very aggressive young general kind of blaze like a meteor across the plains and mountains of Japan
他基本上要让他的弟弟，你知道，在寺院训练的那个，或者无论在哪里被尤达训练的那个，来为他做这件事，对吧？因为他的弟弟显然是更有能力的指挥官。但随后出现了一个转折。多米尼克，确实有一个转折，因为1183年春天，战争确实恢复了，平氏和源氏开始再次直接冲突。这确实见证了平氏对源氏大本营发动了全面攻击。这确实见证了一位非常有魅力、非常有能力、非常有侵略性的年轻将军像流星一样划过日本的平原和山脉
and establish himself as an absolute top samurai legend. But the amazing twist is that this general, is not Yoshitsunei, or at least initially it isn't. Because Kanto is not the only Minamoto stronghold. And listeners may remember from our previous episode that there is also a second Minamoto stronghold. And this is the upland region of Shinano. And this lay to the east of Kyoto and the absolute kind of interior of central Honshu. So it's basically in the middle of Japan. And it's very mountainous, difficult to rain, but not completely inaccessible because there is this river valley that cuts through it. And the river, the queso, helps to open up the Western approaches if you are in Shinano. And these lead to Kyoto.
并确立了自己作为绝对顶级武士传奇的地位。但惊人的转折是，这位将军不是义经，或者至少最初不是。因为关东并不是唯一的源氏据点。听众可能还记得上一集，还有第二个源氏据点。这就是信浓的高地地区。它位于京都以东，处于本州岛中部的绝对腹地。所以它基本上在日本的中间。那里山峦起伏，地形复杂，但并非完全无法进入，因为有一条河谷穿过它。而这条河，木曾川，有助于打开如果你在信浓的话通往西部的通道。这些通道通向京都。
And this means that from the perspective of the Tyra in Kyoto, any concentration of Minamoto forces in Shinano is a real threat. And just such a concentration over the course of the early years of the war is what has been happening. And it's been happening under yet another samurai chief whose name begins with Y and ends in a vow. So listeners will be thrilled to know that there is another of these Minamoto popping up. And this is a guy called Minamoto No Yoshinaka. Before you plunge into that, Tom, let's just pause a second and get these three people in there in clear who they are, because they're so similar. Yoritomo, which guy is Yoritomo again? Yoritomo is the brilliantly cold, ruthless, pragmatic head of the Minamoto clan.
这意味着从京都平氏的角度来看，信浓任何源氏力量的集结都是一个真正的威胁。而在战争初期，正是这种集结一直在发生。而且它是在另一位名字以Y开头、以元音结尾的武士首领领导下发生的。所以听众会很高兴地知道，还有另一位源氏冒了出来。这是一个叫源义仲的人。在你深入探讨之前，汤姆，让我们暂停一下，把这三个人弄清楚，因为他们太相似了。赖朝，赖朝又是哪一个？赖朝是源氏家族那位极其冷酷、无情、务实的领袖。
Right. So, okay, he's the mastermind. Yoshitsune, who is he? He is the younger half-brother, dashing, brilliant, got the warrior monk at his back, King Arthur, Luke Skywalker, that kind of figure. Gotcha. And then the third man, Yoshinaka, you're about to tell us who he is. He is their cousin, right? Yes. So his father had been killed, not by Kiamori, but in a Minimato blood feud. And so he'd grown up slightly off the Tyra radar. They hadn't really kind of worried about him as he was growing up. And he'd grown up in Shinano and made it his stronghold. And he had come to identify with it so strongly that he took the name of the river that ran through it, Kiso. And so I think because it's so confusing to have, you know, all these whys with vowels on the end of their name bubbling around, we should call him Kee's.
没错。所以，好吧，他是策划者。义经，他是谁？他是同父异母的弟弟，风度翩翩、才华横溢，背后有僧兵支持，亚瑟王、卢克·天行者那种人物。明白了。那么第三个人，义仲，你正要告诉我们他是谁。他是他们的堂兄弟，对吧？是的。所以他的父亲不是被清盛杀死的，而是在源氏的血仇中被杀的。所以他在平氏的雷达之外长大。他们在他成长过程中并没有真正担心过他。他在信浓长大，并将其作为自己的据点。他开始强烈地认同那里，以至于他取了流经那里的河流的名字，木曾。所以我认为，因为名字末尾都有元音的Y开头名字太多，让人困惑，我们应该叫他木曾。
He was called Kiso as well as Yoshinaka. So we'll call him Kiso. Brilliant. This is a dream. And by 1183, Kiso in his kind of great mountain fastness east of Kyoto, has become a really pressing threat to the Tyra. And they are starting to worry that he might launch a direct attack on them from Kyoto. But they're also worried that he's established his control over the lowland road that goes
他也被称为木曾，也叫义仲。所以我们叫他木曾。太棒了。这真是个梦想。到1183年，京都以东山区的木曾已经成为平氏一个非常紧迫的威胁。他们开始担心他可能会从京都对他们发动直接攻击。但他们也担心他已经控制了沿着日本北部海岸延伸的低地道路，这也是一种，你知道，它非常容易通行，所以它绕过了本州岛中间的所有这些山脉。他们也不想让他夺取那条道路的控制权。所以1183年春天，平氏派出一支庞大的远征军，据说是10万人，我的意思是，也许没那么多，但很多人，沿着这条沿海道路，沿着北部沿海道路。他们派出如此庞大军队的目的，是为了绝对保证胜利。他们要消灭木曾，然后一旦他们做到了这一点，并且确保了他们的东北侧翼并清除了信浓的源氏力量，
along the coast of northern Japan, which is also a kind of, you know, it's very accessible, so it goes round all these mountains that are in the middle of Honshu. And they don't want him to seize control of that either. And so in the spring of 1183, the Tyra send an enormous expeditionary force, supposedly 100,000 men, I mean, maybe not that much, but a lot of men, along this coastal road, along the northern coastal road. And their aim in sending such an enormous army, is to absolutely guarantee victory. They're going to eliminate Kiso, and then once they've done that, and they've secured their northeastern flank and cleared Shinano of Minamoto forces,
他们就可以向南前往关东，将所有力量转向赖朝，赖朝就在那里，并结束战争。这就是战略。这是一个彻底消灭所有源氏力量的战略，从木曾开始。好计划。还是说不是？因为他们沿着这条路推进，对吧？沿海道路大约200英里，他们赢了几场小规模冲突，平氏。
they can then head southwards towards Kanto, turn all their forces against Yoritomo, who is based there, and finish off the war. So that is the strategy. It's a strategy of the total annihilation of all the Minamoto forces, beginning with Kiso. Good plan. Or is it? Because they advance along this road, don't they? The coastal road for about 200 miles and they win a couple of skirmishes, the Tyra.
然后他们到达了一个山口。我认为，在入侵中这总是一个不祥的时刻。是的。那是5月底，山口叫俱利伽罗。他们听说木曾正从相反方向赶来。所以他们有点冲了过去。他们实际上想在他之前通过山口，对吧？这样他们就可以在另一边的地面上遇见他，
And then they reach a mountain pass. Always an ominous moment, I think, in an invasion. Yes. So it's the end of May and the pass is called Kourikara. And they hear that Kiso is coming the opposite way. So they kind of rush on. And effectively they want to get through the pass before him, don't they? So they can meet him on the kind of on the ground,
但发生了什么？嗯，他们想这样做是因为他们知道他们的人数远远超过了木曾的部队。所以如果他们能在开阔的平原上相遇，那绝对会对他们有利。但当他们到达这个山口，俱利伽罗的顶部时，他们看到了让他们不寒而栗的东西。这是左侧山脊上飘扬的一大片源氏旗帜，比他们原以为木曾能带到战场上的源氏旗帜多得多。显然，他们不想继续沿着山口向下行进到下面的平原，而让自己的侧翼暴露在这支庞大的源氏力量面前。所以他们停止了推进并扎营，基本上
the other side. But what happens? Well, they want to do that because they know that they vastly outnumber the forces that Kiso has. So if they can meet on an open plane, then it will absolutely kind of be to their benefit. But when they reached the top of this pass, Kurokara, they see something that makes their blood run cold. And this is a great mass of Minamoto banners fluttering over the ridge on their left, far more Minamoto banners than they had ever thought that Kiso would have been able to bring into the field. Obviously, they don't. They don't want to continue their march down the pass into the flatlands below with their flank exposed to this vast Minamoto force. And so they halt their advance and make camp and basically
只是在想我们现在该怎么办。这正是木曾希望他们做的，因为旗帜是诱饵。这是一种经典的武士策略。其中大多数是幻影旗帜。所以这些旗帜的景象欺骗了平氏，让他们认为木曾山口顶峰上的人数比他实际拥有的要多得多。这个山口上的实际人数只有3000人。而这些人，多米尼克，是由一个叫尤达的人指挥的。所以，星球大战的回声贯穿了这个故事。是的，他来自达戈巴系统。所以木曾第二天到了，对吧，去加入尤达。是的。
kind of just wondering what do we do now. And this is exactly what Kiso wants them to do because the flags are a decoy. It's a kind of classic samurai stratagem. Most of them are phantom banners. And so the sight of these banners, it tricks the Tyra into thinking that Kiso has far more men on the peak of the pass than he actually does. The actual number of men on this pass is only 3,000. And these men, Dominic, are commanded by a guy called Yoda. So again, the kind of Star Wars echoes are throughout this story. Yeah, he's come from the Degaba system. So Kiso arrives the next day, doesn't he to join you to join Yoda. Yeah.
但他有2万人。他有一支相当大的部队。所以提醒我们平氏有10万人。那是声称的数字？10万人。所以仍然以5比1的比例处于劣势，差不多。但他的计划基本上就像汉尼拔。我的意思是，每一场战斗都回到了汉尼拔的战斗。
But he has 20,000 men. He has a substantial force. So remind us that Tyra had 100,000. That was the claim? 100,000. So it's still outnumbered 5 to 1, pretty much. But his plan is basically he's like a Hannibal. I mean, every battle comes back to Hannibal's battles.
他想包围他们，对吧？基本上利用他们自己荒谬的人数优势，让他们无法机动。他们会互相阻碍。他将能够侧翼包抄他们并进行猛烈的攻击，这将摧毁他们，对吗？嗯，他有一个非常复杂且非常聪明的策略。所以他把他的部队分成了三部分。他和尤达，我喜欢说那个名字。他和尤达现在在山口上方的山脊上，直接面对平氏。
He wants to surround them, doesn't he? And basically use their own ridiculous weight of numbers, make them unmaneuverable. They will get in each other's way. and he will be able to outflank them and make darting attacks that will destroy them, correct? Well, he has a very complicated and very clever stratagem. So he's divided his forces into three. He and Yoda, I love saying that. He and Yoda are now on the ridge above the pass, directly opposite the Tyra.
与此同时，平氏不知道的是，木曾的第二支部队已经在平氏阵地正后方的一处悬崖脚下占据了隐蔽位置，当地人称之为地狱谷。所以，站在通往被称为地狱谷的地方的悬崖边缘，没有任何好处。还有第三支部队，同样没有被平氏观察到。他们根本不知道它的存在，他们正在攀爬平氏阵地之外一条非常宽阔而狭窄的山路。他们的目的是进入平氏的后方并切断他们的退路，这样他们就不能沿着他们来的路撤退。而这第三支部队需要整整一天的时间才能到达他们的位置，因为他们不得不绕很远的路。
Meanwhile, unknown to the Tyra, a second contingent of Kiso's men, have taken up hidden positions far below at the the foot of a precipice directly behind the Tyra positions, which is known locally as Hell Valley. So there's nothing good about being on the edge of a precipice that leads down to somewhere called Hell Valley. There is also a third contingent, again, unobserved by the Tyra. They have no idea that it exists, who are climbing a very wide and narrow mountain path beyond the site of the Tyra. And their aim is to go in the rear of the Tyra and cut off their retreat so that they can't kind of march back down the way that they came. And it's going to take this third contingent a whole extra day to reach their positions because they're having to go kind of, you know, a long
所以当6月2日黎明时分，木曾正在尽他所能拖延时间，让平氏分心，给第三支部队机会进入他们的位置。所以整整一天，木曾和他的手下都在进行经典的武士炫耀表演。这包括大声喊出他们的血统，吹嘘他们有多么显赫，发出挑战，进行仪式化的射箭表演，所有这些事情。
way around. And so as the second of June dawns, Kiso is doing all that he can to kill time, to keep the Tyra distracted, to give that third contingent the opportunity to get into their positions. So all day long, Kiso and his men are kind of engaging in classic displays of. of samurai peacocking. So this involves shouting out their lineage, boasting about, you know, how distinguished they are, issuing challenges, engaging in ritualized displays of archery, all this kind of thing.
在《平家物语》中，我们关于这场战争的伟大来源，这些表演通常被描述为在实际战斗中发生，我认为这显然没有发生。想象人们在战斗中停下来大声喊出他们的血统和所有这些类似的事情太荷马史诗了。是的，是的，当然。但我认为，当你有机会对敌人大喊大叫时，这绝对是他们正在做的事情。我们在《平家物语》中被告知，平氏怀疑没有阴谋将他们驱赶向峡谷，便配合他们，可怜的人们，直到光线开始变暗。当太阳落山时，平氏第一次注意到
And in the tale of the Heke, our great source for this war, these displays are often described as happening in the context of actual battles themselves, which I think is clearly didn't happen. It's too homeric to imagine that people are stopping in the middle of the battle and shouting out their lineage and all this similar thing. Yeah, yeah, of course. But I think that when you have the opportunity to kind of shout at an enemy, it's absolutely what they're up to. And we're told in the tale of the Heke and the Tyra, suspecting no scheme to drive them towards the ravine, played along with them, poor men, until the light began to fail. And as the sun sets, so the Tyra notice for the first time.
在他们的后方，一支源氏部队开始集结并排开阵势，现在切断了他们的退路。就在他们注意到这一点时，太阳落山了，黑暗降临，是夜晚，然后突然间，一股巨大的力量冲下斜坡向他们袭来。平氏看到了一大片滚滚而来的火把，他们感觉到大地开始震动。当然，他们很害怕，以为一支似乎凭空出现的庞大军队正在攻击他们，他们动摇了，开始崩溃，他们转身。但那不是一支庞大的军队。那是一群巨大的牛，角上绑着燃烧的火把。所以，又是汉尼拔，听我们汉尼拔系列的人。那是他喜欢用的那种把戏。
that in their rear, a Minamoto force is starting to assemble and drawing up ranks and is now blocking off their retreat. And even as they notice this, the sun sets, darkness descends, it's night, and then all at once storming down the slope towards them. The Tyra Sea, a great rolling surge of torches and they feel the earth starting to shake. And of course, they're terrified that a massive army that seems to have sprung from nowhere is attacking them and they falter and they start to break and they turn. But it's not a massive army. It's an enormous herd of oxen with burning torches tied to their horns. And so again, Barry Hannibal, people who, you know, who listened to our series on Hannibal. That was the kind of trick. He'd
牛群狂奔，撞向平氏，许多人被撞得跌跌撞撞，掉进了他们身后张开的巨大峡谷中。其他人被践踏在脚下。其他人被源氏部队砍倒，他们现在已经开始攻击他们，既来自木曾和尤达驻扎的山脊，也来自那支在他们后方行进的第三支部队。源氏没有逃脱的机会，即使是那些活着到达地狱谷底部的人也没有，因为那是第三支部队等待的地方，那些为了这一刻而埋伏的人。我们被告知，所有这些庞大的数字，成千上万的人行进到了俱利伽罗山口的顶峰。
love to pull. And the oxen stampede smashing into the Tyra, many of whom are sent stumbling, falling into the vast ravine that yawns behind them. Others are trampled underfoot. Others are cut down by the Minamoto forces who've now begun to attack them, both from the ridge where Kiso and Yoda are stationed, and also that third contingent who are marching down in their rear. And there isn't any escape for the Minamoto, not even for those who make it alive to the bottom of Hell Valley because that is where the third contingent of men is waiting, the people who've been lying in ambush for exactly this moment. And we're told that all these vast numbers, these thousands upon thousands of men had marched up to the summit of the Kurikara Pass.
而在这些巨大的数字中，只有2000人幸存。所以引用《平家物语》，父亲坠落，儿子坠落，兄弟坠落，长兄幼弟，领主坠落，身后的家臣，人马堆叠，马压在人身上，一遍又一遍，直到坐骑和骑手，7万平氏，肩并肩堵塞了张开的峡谷，泉水流血，死者堆积如山，直到今天，人们依然这样说，
And of these huge numbers, only 2,000 survive. So to quote the tale of the haki, down hurtled the father, down the son, down the brothers, elder than younger, down the Lord. his retainer behind him, men piling on horses, horses on men, over and over till mounts and riders, 70,000 of the Tyra, edge to edge choked the yawning ravine, springs ran blood, the dead lay in mounds, to this day, so it is told,
箭矢击中缺口，剑痕刻在岩石上，俱利伽罗，上下皆是。结果是武士指挥官有史以来最毁灭性和决定性的胜利，对吧？因为平氏的入侵被击退了。平氏军队处于混乱的溃败中，木曾以极大的偏见追击他们，不是吗？他确实这样做了，因为他想完成溃败。
arrows strike nicks and sword cuts mark the rocks, up and down, Kourikara. The result of this is the most crushing and decisive victory ever won by a samurai commander, right? because the Tyra invasion has been driven back. The Tyra forces are in headlong chaotic retreat, and Kiso pursues them with extreme prejudice, doesn't he? He does because he wants to complete the route.
所以现在战争的前景悬着一个巨大的问题。你知道，平氏还能卷土重来吗？他们还能继续战争吗？如果不能，这对源氏意味着什么？当然，木曾的惊人胜利对源氏首领赖朝意味着什么，他与此毫无关系？堂兄弟之间是否有可能闹翻？因为赖朝不是那种喜欢被意外抢走风头的人。所以难以置信的紧张，多米尼克。
And so huge question now, hanging over the prospects of the war. You know, are the Tyra going to be able to make a comeback? Will they be able to continue the war at all? If they can't, what does this mean for the Minamoto? And also, of course, what does Kiso's stunning victory mean for Yoritomo, the head of the Minamoto, who's had nothing to do with this? Is there potential perhaps for the cousins to fall out? Because Yoritomo is not the kind of man who likes being unexpectedly upstaged. So unbelievable tension, Dominic.
难以置信的紧张。我们可能应该在这里休息一下，因为太紧张了。但真是个悬念。休息后回来看看接下来会发生什么。啊，我的手套在哪里？来吧，热量。冬天很难，但你的杂货不必如此。这个冬天，保持温暖。
Incredible tension. We should probably take a break here because it's so tense. But what a cliffhanger. Return after the break to find out what happens next. Ah, where are my gloves? Come on, heat. Winter is hard, but your groceries don't have to be. This winter, stay warm.
点击横幅在voila.ca在线订购您的杂货。无需离开家即可享受店内价格。您会在网上找到与店内相同的常规价格。许多促销活动在店内和网上都有，尽管有些可能会有所不同。嗨，我是《政治的其余部分》的阿拉斯泰尔·坎贝尔，我在这里告诉你们一个非常重要的采访，现在在我们的播客频道《政治的其余部分：领导力》上发布。本周我采访了我们这个时代最具决定性的政治人物之一，乌克兰总统弗拉基米尔·泽连斯基。这是一次引人入胜的采访，反思了他的成长经历，
Tap the banner to order your groceries online at voila.ca. Enjoy in-store prices without leaving your home. You'll find the same regular prices online as in-store. Many promotions are available both in-store and online, though some may vary. Hi there, Aleister Campbell here from The Rest is Politics, and I'm here to tell you about a really important interview that's out now on our podcast channel, The Rest is Politics Leading. This week I spoke to one of the defining political figures of our time, President Vrodmere Zelenskyy of Ukraine. It is a fascinating interview, reflects on his upbringing,
反思了他的政治崛起，反思了他在俄罗斯入侵期间如何留在基辅，重新定义了战时领导力。他非常强烈地警告我们，不要让任何人，尤其是唐纳德·特朗普，相信弗拉基米尔·普京的谎言，即停火可能作为战略暂停，而不是真正和平的标志。他对比普京提供了非常直率的评估，审视了他敌人的力量、战略，以及至关重要的，他在一场战争中的弱点
reflects on his political rise, reflects on how he stayed in Kiev during Russia's invasion, redefining leadership in wartime. And he warns us very much against anyone, not least Donald Trump, falling for Vladimir Putin's lies, ones that ceasefires may serve as strategic pause rather than a sign of genuine peace. He offers a very blunt assessment of Putin, looks at his enemy's strength, strategy, and crucially, his weaknesses in a war
他确信俄罗斯无法获胜。他没有对国际反应有所保留，有时，特别是来自美国的反应。如果您想了解更多，我希望您想了解，请在您获取播客的任何地方搜索《政治的其余部分：领导力》。现在，回到你们的节目。欢迎大家回到《政治的其余部分》，
he has convinced Russia cannot win. And he doesn't hold back on the international response, at times, particularly from the US. If you'd like to hear more, and I hope you do, search the rest is politics leading wherever you get your podcasts. And now, back to your show. Welcome back, everybody, to the rest of the,
他确信俄罗斯无法获胜。而且他对于国际社会的反应，有时特别是美国的反应，也毫不避讳。如果您想了解更多，我希望您会去听，请在您获取播客的任何平台搜索《The Rest Is Politics Leading》。现在，回到您的节目。欢迎大家回到《The Rest Is Politics》,
history what's tension and what's a cliffhanger we are now in early august 1183 so seven weeks after queso won that tremendous victory unexpected victory with this blazing oxen and whatnot at the pass of kuri kara and kiotto the imperial capital is a city on the edge a city in panic because kiso is closing in so he'd won a second victory which we won't massively go into a hundred miles east of Kyoto at a place called Shinohara and the survivors, the refugees have been drifting into the capital and the sound of approaching drums from the east of the Minamoto forces has been growing louder and louder and louder. Yeah, and again, Kiso has split his forces into three. So he is leading a contingent that's coming directly from the east. There's another Minamoto
历史，什么是紧张感，什么是悬念？现在是1183年8月初，也就是木曾义仲在俱利伽罗峠之战中，凭借火牛阵等手段取得那场惊人且出人意料的胜利七周之后。京都作为帝都，正处于崩溃边缘，陷入恐慌，因为木曾义仲正在逼近。他之前在京都以东一百英里的筱原又取得了一场胜利（我们就不详细展开了），幸存者和难民纷纷涌入京城，从东方传来的源氏军队的鼓声也越来越响。是的，而且木曾义仲再次将他的军队分成了三路。他亲自率领一支部队直接从东方进军。还有另一支源氏
expeditionary force which is closing in on Kyoto from the south. And there is a third one that has gone right the way around and is now coming from the west. So the trap, in other words, is close to snapping shut. And on the 13th of August, the leader of the Tyra clan, who is the eldest surviving son of Kiamori, a man called Munamori. And he, it has to be said, is not a very impressive bigger. He is a shadow of his father. And Munamori gives orders for the evacuation of the capital. So to quote the, the, the of the hake. Men, saddled horses, tightened girths and galloped north, southeast and west, carrying things to hide. And Monomori orders the headquarters of the Tyra in Kyoto to be put to the torch
远征军正从南方逼近京都。第三支部队则绕了一大圈，现在正从西方赶来。换句话说，包围圈即将收紧。8月13日，平氏家族的领袖，也就是清盛的长子平宗盛——必须得说，他并不是一个令人印象深刻的领导者，只是他父亲的影子——下令撤离京城。引用《平家物语》的话：“人们给马备上鞍，勒紧肚带，向北、向南、向西飞奔，带着东西去躲藏。”宗盛下令放火烧毁平氏在京都的总部，
so that there will be nothing for Kiso to seize. And I think the atmosphere is very Saigon, 1975. There's a sense of, you know, people fleeing. You need to kind of burn the evidence of your occupation and you have this pool of black smoke starting to drift across the capital. Well, you say people fleeing, but there are some people in particular whose fate is crucial and chief among them. We haven't really talked about the imperial family specifically. So what's going on with them? Well, we said how they're kind of ciphers. That's not entirely true. They are players. Their key role is to provide legitimacy to whoever controls them. And so it's really important for the Tyra that they keep the emperor in their hands because if they
这样木曾义仲就什么也抢不到了。我觉得当时的氛围很像1975年的西贡。有一种人们在逃亡的感觉。你需要烧掉你占领过的证据，你可以看到滚滚黑烟开始在京城上空飘散。嗯，你说人们在逃亡，但有些人的命运至关重要，其中最主要的就是皇室。我们还没怎么专门谈过他们。他们的情况如何？嗯，我们说过他们就像傀儡，但这不完全正确。他们是博弈者。他们的关键作用是为控制他们的人提供合法性。所以对平氏来说，把天皇掌握在自己手中非常重要，因为如果他们
lose the emperor to Kiso, then it's Kiso and the Minamoto who will become the defenders of legitimacy and the Tyra will immediately kind of be transformed into outlaws. And so that evening, as the Tyra headquarters is burning and all the various Tyra lords are preparing to evacuate Kyoto. Monomori comes to the imperial palace and he comes into the presence of his sister, Ken Raimonin, who is the mother of the emperor, so the daughter of Kiomori. And he speaks to her in the strictest confidence. And he says to her, I believe that the world would somehow always be as we knew it,
失去了天皇，让天皇落入木曾义仲手中，那么木曾义仲和源氏就会成为合法性的捍卫者，而平氏会立刻变成叛军。所以那天晚上，当平氏总部在燃烧，各位平氏贵族准备撤离京都时，宗盛来到皇宫，见到了他的妹妹建礼门院（天皇的母亲，清盛的女儿）。他极其秘密地对她说：“我曾以为世界会永远像我们所知的那样，
but now you see everything has changed. And he says to Ken Raimonin, you have to go and you have to take your son, the five-year-old, Antoku the emperor, you have to take him with you. And so mother and son leave the next morning at six o'clock in the imperial palanquin and they take with them crucially the imperial regalia. And this is a mirror, a jewel and a sword that had been brought to earth two millennia before by the grandson of the sun goddess. And this matters because you cannot become an emperor without that regalia. It's just not possible. So they set off the emperor, his mother, all the Tyra lords, the imperial regalia. And as they abandoned Kyoto, so we're told, clouds trailed about the
但现在你看，一切都变了。”他对建礼门院说：“你必须走，你必须带上你的儿子，五岁的安德天皇，你必须带他一起走。”于是，母子俩在第二天早上六点乘坐御辇离开，关键是他们带走了三神器。这是一面镜子、一块玉和一把剑，据说是两千年前由天照大神的孙子带到人间的。这很重要，因为没有这些神器就无法成为天皇。这是不可能的。于是他们出发了，天皇、他的母亲、所有的平氏贵族，还有三神器。当他们离开京都时，据说云雾缭绕在
eastern hills and a bright moon lit the dawn. Everywhere cocks were crowing. No one had dreamed it would come to this. And the emperor is going with his uncles and the other Tyra lords, and they abound for the inner sea and the fleet which remains their great strength because as we said, the Tyra are the lords of the ocean, the lords of the inner sea and the waters beyond it. And because the Minamoto have no ships,
东山之上，明月照亮了黎明。到处都是公鸡的啼鸣。没人想到会变成这样。天皇跟随他的叔叔们和其他平氏贵族，前往内海，那里有他们依然强大的舰队，因为正如我们所说，平氏是海洋的主人，是内海及其周边水域的主人。而由于源氏没有船只，
this offers them a prospect of continuing the war. Yeah, but one person doesn't go with them. And this is somebody called Gosurakawa. And Gosurikawa is the most, cunning and slippery, isn't he, of all the what they call the cloistered emperors. So explain to us the role of go-shurakawa. So we've mentioned before a cloistered emperor is an emperor who has reigned and then abdicated. And this was absolutely standard practice. It was a way in which the kind of the various lords who effectively controlled the empire were always able to ensure that no emperor
这让他们有了继续战争的希望。是的，但有一个人没有跟他们走。这个人叫后白河。后白河是所有所谓的“院政”天皇中最狡猾、最圆滑的一个，不是吗？那么请给我们解释一下后白河的角色。我们之前提到过，院政天皇是指已经退位的天皇。这在当时是绝对的标准做法。这是一种方式，让那些实际上控制帝国的贵族们能够确保没有任何一位天皇
was in a position to kind of establish the supremacy over them. So go-shurikawa was slightly unusual. because normally the emperors would rule as children, as boys, and then have to abdicate as they were approaching adolescents. Gosherakawa had come to the throne in his late 20s, and he, of course, had been obliged to abdicate as all emperors were after, he'd ruled it only for three years. But because he was that much older, and because he was naturally very shrewd and cunning,
能够处于建立对他们统治地位的位置。所以后白河有点不同，因为通常天皇在孩童时期即位，然后在接近青春期时就必须退位。后白河是在二十多岁时即位的，当然，他像所有天皇一样，在统治了仅仅三年后就被迫退位。但因为他年纪大得多，而且天生非常精明狡猾，
he'd remained a very active player in court politics. And he had very reluctantly accepted. the supremacy of the Tyra. You know, he'd found it a humiliation to be subordinated to a samurai lord. And Prince Machihito, who led that rebellion that we finished with in the previous episode, the guy who fought by the bridge and ended up being killed there, Prince Macha Hito had been Goshirakaa's son. And somehow, Goshirikawa had avoided suspicion of complicity in that plot. I mean, he must have been embroiled. But Kiomori kind of left him alone. And he's still very much on the scene. And now, with the Tyra leaving and Kiso fast approaching the capital, his chance
他仍然是宫廷政治中非常活跃的参与者。他非常不情愿地接受了平氏的统治。你知道，他觉得屈辱，因为要屈从于一个武士领主。而我们在上一集结尾提到的那个领导叛乱的以仁王，那个在桥边战斗并最终在那里被杀的人，就是后白河的儿子。不知何故，后白河避免了被怀疑参与那个阴谋。我的意思是，他肯定卷入其中了。但清盛某种程度上放过了他。他依然活跃在舞台上。现在，随着平氏离开，木曾义仲迅速逼近京城，他的机会
has come. So on the 13th of August, as the Tyra are evacuating Kyoto, Gosherakawa slips away unnoticed from Kyoto. And we're told the cloistered emperor stole away to seek refuge on Mount Hiya. And Mount Hia is east of Kyoto, and it's where one of Japan's most famous monastery stood, still stands to this day. But it was also more saliently where Kiso and his army had just arrived. And so the big question is, can the cloistered emperor, Goshirikawa, and the great samurai warlord Kiso do business? And Dominic, indeed they can. Well, that's exciting. So they clearly strike a deal because Goshiakoua, returns to Kyoto a few days later.
来了。所以8月13日，当平氏撤离京都时，后白河悄悄溜走了。据说这位法皇溜走去比叡山避难。比叡山在京都以东，那里有日本最著名的寺院之一，至今仍屹立在那里。但更重要的是，木曾义仲和他的军队刚刚抵达那里。所以最大的问题是，法皇后白河和伟大的武士军阀木曾义仲能达成合作吗？多米尼克，他们确实可以。哇，那太令人兴奋了。所以他们显然达成了协议，因为后白河几天后就回到了京都。
So 17th of August, and he's got an escort at this point of 50,000 mounted warriors and above them are flying the banners of the Minamoto. The white banners of the Minamoto said this is a massive twist. It is. So again, the tale of the Hakey, no such banner had been seen to enter the capital for a good 20 years and more. These were astonishing events. And Gosherakawa, with this escort of Minamoto Warriors, is able now, back in Kyoto, to set himself up in a splendid palace. And this is called the Hojuchi, and it includes a temple with a kind of incredibly vulgar sounding golden hall.
那是8月17日，此时他有五万名骑兵护卫，他们头顶飘扬着源氏的旗帜。源氏的白旗，这是一个巨大的转折。确实。同样是《平家物语》记载，已经有二十多年没见过这样的旗帜进入京城了。这些都是惊人的事件。后白河在源氏武士的护卫下，现在能够回到京都，在华丽的宫殿中安顿下来。这叫法住寺殿，里面有一座听起来极其庸俗的金色大厅。
It's got an ornamental lake. It's absolutely wonderful. And Gosherakawa settles himself in there with great enthusiasm. And from the Hujiji, he issues decrees, which confirm to the world that everything has indeed been turned upside down and that the Tyra are now the outlaws and it's the Minamoto who are the defenders of the throne. And Gosherakawa formally strips 160 Tyra lords of their court offices. And of course, there is a further problem, which is that they don't have the emperor,
它有一个装饰性的湖泊。真是太棒了。后白河满怀热情地在那里安顿下来。从法住寺殿，他发布了法令，向世界证实一切确实已经天翻地覆，平氏现在是叛军，而源氏是皇位的捍卫者。后白河正式剥夺了160名平氏贵族的官职。当然，还有一个进一步的问题，那就是他们没有天皇，
but Gosherakawa thinks that he has a solution. And he eyes up Antikou, the emperor's, his little half-brother. He's only about two years old at this point. And he picks up this little boy, bounces him on his lap. And he sobs to think I had never seen this little boy before. And he prophesies that the boy's descendants will rule for a hundred generations, clearly lining him up to become a replacement emperor. But there is this problem.
但后白河认为他有一个解决方案。他看中了安德天皇的小半弟。他当时只有两岁左右。他抱起这个小男孩，放在膝盖上颠了颠。他啜泣着想到，我以前从未见过这个小男孩。他预言这个男孩的后代将统治一百代，显然是想让他成为替代天皇。但有一个问题。
they don't have the imperial regalia because the Tira have taken it with them. It's with Antikou. So that is an issue, but it's not an insuperable one because Goshaerakawa has a great general who can go after the Tira and hopefully get the imperial regalia back. And this, of course, is Kiso. And Gosherakawa gives Kiso an absolutely splendid title. And this is the Asahi Shogun, the general of the rising sun. Okay, that is a good name.
他们没有三神器，因为平氏把它们带走了。它们在安德天皇那里。所以这是一个问题，但并非无法克服，因为后白河有一位伟大的将军，可以去追击平氏，并有望夺回三神器。这当然就是木曾义仲。后白河给了木曾义仲一个极其华丽的头衔。这就是“朝日将军”。好吧，那是个好名字。
Unfortunately, Kesea doesn't quite live up to that tremendous name, does he? Because basically, he's come from the sticks. He's come from the kind of agricultural badlands of Shinano, the kind of mountains. And he and his men do not behave with the elegance and courtesy that is expected of visitors to the imperial capital. No, so it's like, you know, Buckingham Palace has been taken over by the Wurzels or something. So Kiso's samurai roaming around Kyoto kind of pillaging and drinking cider and. driving tractors and all that kind of thing. Right.
不幸的是，木曾义仲并没有完全配得上那个响亮的名字，对吧？因为基本上，他是从乡下来的。他来自信浓那种农业荒地，那种山区。他和他的手下并没有表现出作为帝都访客所应有的优雅和礼貌。不，所以这就像是白金汉宫被一群乡巴佬接管了一样。木曾义仲的武士在京都到处游荡，抢劫、喝苹果酒、开拖拉机之类的。对。
And this is terrible for Goshirokawa, who's been raised in, you know, the sophistication and delicacy of the imperial court and doesn't want these bumpkins in the slightest. And so he looks around for another horse to back. And of course, there is really only the one option. And this is Moritomo no Yoritomo, the Lord of Kanto, the head of the Minamoto clan, Kiso's cousin.
这对后白河来说太糟糕了，他在皇宫的精致和细腻中长大，一点也不想要这些乡巴佬。所以他环顾四周，寻找另一匹马下注。当然，真的只有一个选择。这就是关东之主、源氏族长、木曾义仲的表亲——源赖朝。
But he and Kiso are in alliance, right? Well, Yoritomo has been watching with mixed emotions. I think it's fair to say. On the one hand, he's delighted that Kiso has destroyed the Taira's hold on Kyoto. On the other hand, he doesn't really want Kiso to have too much power because then he might rival himself for control of the Minamoto clan. And this is why Yorotomo is very interested to hear from Gosherakawa, and Gosherakawa is very, very interested in Yorotomo. Tomo is not a bumpkin. He has immense military reserves, so he has at least as many men as Kiso. And above all, you know, basically he's a completely ruthless bastard who is jealous of Kiso and resentful of his success. And Gosherakawa is shrewd enough to realize that there is great scope here for making mischief. And so he writes Yoritomo a secret letter, essentially inviting him to come to Kyoto and liberate the city.
但他和木曾义仲是盟友，对吧？嗯，赖朝一直带着复杂的情绪在观察。我觉得可以公平地说。一方面，他很高兴木曾义仲摧毁了平氏对京都的控制。另一方面，他并不真的希望木曾义仲拥有太大的权力，因为那样他可能会在源氏家族的控制权上与自己竞争。这就是为什么赖朝对后白河的消息非常感兴趣，而后白河对赖朝也非常、非常感兴趣。赖朝不是乡巴佬。他拥有巨大的军事储备，所以他至少拥有和木曾义仲一样多的人马。最重要的是，你知道，他基本上是一个完全冷酷无情的混蛋，嫉妒木曾义仲并对他取得的成功感到愤恨。后白河足够精明，意识到这里有很大的捣乱空间。于是他给赖朝写了一封秘密信件，本质上是邀请他来京都解放这座城市，
from his cousin, who Goshirokawa describes as the wild monkey of Kiso. So meanwhile, Kiso is oblivious to this, and Kiso has been saying to go Shurikawa, my plan is I'm going to march on the canto and I'm going to get rid of Yoritomo. He's completely oblivious to the fact that his patron is in touch with the one man that he's actually planning to go and eliminate. Yes, and this isn't what Goshirokawa wants at all, because Goshiakawa actually wants the regalia back. That's his priority because he wants to enshrine.
从他的表亲手中，后白河称其为“木曾的野猴子”。与此同时，木曾义仲对此一无所知，他一直在对后白河说：“我的计划是进军关东，除掉赖朝。”他完全不知道他的赞助人正在与他计划去消灭的那个人保持联系。是的，这根本不是后白河想要的，因为后白河实际上想要夺回三神器。那是他的首要任务，因为他想供奉
the reigning emperor's little brother, go toba he's called, as the new emperor. And so he says, you know, don't bother attacking Yorotomo. Don't do that yet. Go and attack the Tyra. They're the priority. Go and eliminate them. And Kiso can see the force of this argument because he doesn't want to allow the, the Tyra to kind of recover from their meltdown. They've still got their fleet, the seas of theirs, there's still a kind of massive brooding threat. You know, and Kiso wants to get the imperial regalia back as well. He wants a new emperor. He wants to have this little boy directly under his thumb. Yeah.
现任天皇的小弟弟，也就是后鸟羽，作为新天皇。所以他说：“你知道，别去攻击赖朝。现在还不要那样做。去攻击平氏。他们才是优先目标。去消灭他们。”木曾义仲能看出这个论点的力量，因为他不想让平氏从崩溃中恢复过来。他们仍然拥有舰队，海洋是他们的，这仍然是一个巨大的威胁。你知道，木曾义仲也想夺回三神器。他想要一位新天皇。他想把这个小男孩直接控制在自己手中。是的。
And so that autumn, when Kiso leaves Kyoto at the head of his troops again, he is targeting not Yoritomo, but the Taira. So just hold on on that. Goshirokawa suggesting that. Is that a ruse? Is that a part of a plot? That's genuine. Well, Goseerikawa's priority is to eliminate the Taira.
所以那年秋天，当木曾义仲率军离开京都时，他的目标不是赖朝，而是平氏。等等，后白河建议那样做。那是个诡计吗？那是阴谋的一部分吗？那是真心的。嗯，后白河的首要任务是消灭平氏。
Okay. And also he wants an alliance with Yoritomo, so he doesn't want Kiso going off and attacking Yorotomo rather than the Tira. He doesn't want Kiso to be killed in this attack or anything like that. I think he'd quite like it if he was. I mean, that would be, you know, that would solve all kinds of problems. I mean, every time Kesea goes off and fights a war, there is always a prospect that he might end up dead. So, go Shirikawa is basically trying to get him out of the capital.
好的。而且他也想和赖朝结盟，所以他不希望木曾义仲去攻击赖朝而不是平氏。他并不希望木曾义仲在这次攻击中被杀或类似的事情。我想如果他死了，他会很高兴的。我的意思是，那会解决各种各样的问题。我的意思是，每次木曾义仲去打仗，总是有可能最终战死。所以，后白河基本上是想把他赶出京城。
And if he dies in battle, then, you know, that's brilliant. And if he defeats Satira and gets the imperial regalia back, then again, you know, every which way, go Shirikawa is a winner. So he's playing quite a shrewd and subtle game. Now, in the event, Kiso's campaign against the Taira goes very badly wrong. Kiso has never fought at sea. You know, he's rustled up a kind of makeshift fleet, but it gets very badly mauled. And on the same day that he's defeated at sea, a task force that he's sent by land to attack the Tyra is also defeated. So he returns in a slightly bedraggled state.
如果他在战斗中死了，那太棒了。如果他击败了平氏并夺回了三神器，那么无论如何，后白河都是赢家。所以他玩的是一个相当精明和微妙的游戏。结果，木曾义仲对平氏的战役进行得非常糟糕。木曾义仲从未在海上作战过。你知道，他拼凑了一支临时舰队，但损失惨重。就在他在海上战败的同一天，他派去陆路攻击平氏的特遣部队也战败了。所以他以一种相当狼狈的状态回来了。
And just to put Kiso in an even worse mood, when he gets back to Kyoto, he discovers what Goshaakawa has been up to with Yorotomo. essentially trying to kind of elbow him aside and kind of build bridges with Yoritomo. And he is understandably furious. And what's more, Gosherakawa has formerly condemned Kiso's men for robbing all the local farmers, for going out from the city and kind of robbing their storehouses and knicking all their rice and all that kind of thing. And Kiso is furious. There are paddy fields everywhere.
为了让木曾义仲的心情更糟，当他回到京都时，他发现了后白河与赖朝之间的勾当。本质上是试图把他挤到一边，并与赖朝建立联系。他理所当然地愤怒了。更重要的是，后白河正式谴责木曾义仲的手下抢劫当地农民，从城里出去抢劫他们的粮仓，偷走他们所有的稻米之类的东西。木曾义仲愤怒了。到处都是稻田。
What business does he have this cloistered emperor? censoring them for feeding their horses, rice leaves from a few. So, Kita, you can understand, is pretty pissed off by this. And so being the man that he is, a man fond of kind of decisive, dramatic action, he takes the obvious course. He launches a coup and he marches on the Hujogi Palace, you know, this great place with the lake and the Golden Hall and everything, you know, with his men. It's not an easy nut to crack because the Hujogi Palace is guarded by.
这位法皇有什么资格审查他们喂马的行为？从少数人那里拿走稻叶。所以，木曾义仲，你可以理解，对此非常生气。作为一个喜欢果断、戏剧性行动的人，他采取了显而易见的做法。他发动了政变，率领手下向法住寺殿进军，你知道，那个有湖泊、金殿等等的宏伟地方。这不是一个容易攻克的堡垒，因为法住寺殿由
by a crack squad of warrior monks. No. So, you know, they're not sort of lightly challenged. And also, of course, there's the fact that this is the first time a cloistered emperor has been directly attacked by samurai. And so the shock to, you know, what is centuries' worth of respect for the imperial office is off the scale. Goshirakawa, you know, he may no longer be ruling emperor, but he had.
一支精锐的僧兵部队守卫。不。所以，你知道，他们不是那种容易被挑战的人。而且，当然，这是第一次有法皇直接受到武士的攻击。因此，对几个世纪以来对皇权的尊重所造成的冲击是巨大的。后白河，你知道，他可能不再是执政天皇，但他曾经
been emperor and he is descended from the sun goddess. And so at the palace gates, Kiso's men are met by an unarmed chamberlain who addresses them in the most outraged terms. In days gone by, this chamberlain says, when a herald read out the sovereign's decree, dead plants and trees put forth flowers, fruit promptly ripened on the bow and demon powers bowed in a sense. And Kesea response to this is silence him. And he orders a full-blown assault. And a storm of flame-tipped arrows are sent flying into the palace. It's fittings, its timbers, blaze into fire.
是天皇，他是天照大神的后裔。所以，在宫门前，木曾义仲的手下遇到了一个手无寸铁的侍从，他以极其愤怒的言辞对他们说：“在过去，”这位侍从说，“当传令官宣读主上的诏书时，枯木也会开花，果实会迅速成熟，恶魔也会低头。”木曾义仲对此的回应是：“让他闭嘴。”他下令发动全面进攻。一阵火矢射入宫殿。它的配件、木材，燃起了大火。
The Chamberlain flees. So actually do most of the monks. I mean, they may be warrior monks, but they're not prepared to stand up to Kiso's battle-hardened samurai. And those who do say are slaughtered, vast piles of heads are raised. the heads of a hundred of the guards employed by Gosherakawa in the palace are harvested, stuck on spikes along the river bank. And meanwhile, listeners may be wondering, what of Gosherakawa himself,
侍从逃跑了。大多数僧侣也逃了。我的意思是，他们可能是僧兵，但他们没准备好对抗木曾义仲久经沙场的武士。那些留下来的人被屠杀，堆起了巨大的头颅堆。后白河在宫中雇佣的一百名守卫的头颅被收割，插在河岸的尖桩上。与此同时，听众可能想知道，后白河本人怎么样了，
the kind of slippery conniving, calculating cloistered emperor? Well, those guards who had not been slaughtered and decapitated had tried to bundle him into a palanquin, and they had tried to bundle the infant, soon-to-be emperor Gotoba, into a boat and row him out onto the lake. But the samurai had come after both of them. They'd been taken prisoner. And Gosherakawa was put effectively under house arrest in a second palace. And Gotoba, this little boy, he was escorted to not even a palace, just to a private mansion. And the tale of that, the Heke cannot, you know, just kind of goes over.
那个圆滑、狡诈、精于算计的法皇？嗯，那些没有被屠杀和斩首的守卫曾试图把他塞进轿子里，并试图把婴儿、即将成为天皇的后鸟羽塞进船里，划到湖上。但武士追上了他们俩。他们被俘虏了。后白河实际上被软禁在第二座宫殿里。而后鸟羽，这个小男孩，被护送到甚至不是宫殿的地方，只是一个私人宅邸。关于那个故事，《平家物语》无法，你知道，只是……
with the horror and the pathos of this scene. The pathetic nature of this progress truly defies description. And it's such a, it's such a historic moment because, you know, the golden age of Imperial Kuto was, was clearly over by this point, an age that had been characterized by incredible respect for the emperor, kind of painstaking devotion to etiquette, a refusal. all essentially to have kind of dealings at all with samurai. But even so, the treatment that is being meted out by Kiso to both a former and reigning emperor is understandably greeted with complete shock across Japan.
带着这个场景的恐怖和悲怆。这种行径的悲惨性质确实无法形容。这是一个如此具有历史意义的时刻，因为，你知道，帝国京都的黄金时代在这一点上显然已经结束了，一个以对天皇的难以置信的尊重、对礼仪的刻苦奉献、拒绝与武士有任何往来为特征的时代。但即便如此，木曾义仲对前任和现任天皇所采取的待遇，在日本各地理所当然地受到了完全的震惊。
Nothing like it has ever been seen before. More shocking than the what happens to the Roman emperors at the end of the Western Roman Empire, surely, because of the court rituals, the ethos of course. the ethos of courtesy and elegance and respect and deference and all of that was so much more pronounced in Japan than it was in Rome. Am I right? We compared Kyoto to Versailles. If the Mongols had sacked Louis XIV's France.
以前从未见过这样的事情。肯定比西罗马帝国末期罗马皇帝的遭遇更令人震惊，因为宫廷仪式、礼仪的道德准则。礼貌、优雅、尊重和顺从的道德准则在日本比在罗马要显著得多。我说得对吗？我们将京都比作凡尔赛宫。如果蒙古人洗劫了路易十四的法国。
Yeah. Or something. Yeah. It's something like that. Yeah. It's seen. I mean, it's treating the emperor who should be treated or, you know, who's the descendant of a goddess, cosmically mandated, with this lack of respect.
是的。或者类似的事情。是的。就是那样。是的。这是一种景象。我的意思是，对待应该被对待的天皇，或者，你知道，他是女神的后裔，宇宙赋予权力的，却缺乏这种尊重。
You know, it's like seeing Marie Antoinette in a, you know, in a wagon. That's shocking. But there's one more contender who's still around, and that is this guy, Yoritomo. He's the cousin of Kiso. This must be a gift to him because they are now implacable enemies. And for Yorotomo, his cause now has legitimacy because he can say I'm defending the empire against this country bumpkin, can't he? It's brilliant for Yorotomo.
你知道，这就像看到玛丽·安托瓦内特在马车里一样。那很令人震惊。但还有一个竞争者仍然存在，那就是这个家伙，赖朝。他是木曾义仲的表亲。这对他来说一定是一份礼物，因为他们现在是不共戴天的敌人。对于赖朝来说，他的事业现在有了合法性，因为他可以说我正在保卫帝国免受这个乡巴佬的侵害，不是吗？这对赖朝来说太棒了。
And we said how he always waits for the perfect moment before striking, always waits for opportunity to be everything that he needs it to be. and I think the opportunities for him now are twofold. So as you say, he can launch an attack on Kaiso, and if he defeats Kaiso, sees control of Kyoto, and present it as his defense of imperial legitimacy and also the fact that he is bringing peace to a suffering land. Remember that he had been supplying grain to the starving
我们说过他总是等待完美的时机才出击，总是等待机会成为他所需要的一切。我认为他现在的机会是双重的。正如你所说，他可以对木曾义仲发动攻击，如果他击败了木曾义仲，夺取了京都的控制权，并将其表现为他对皇室合法性的捍卫，以及他正在为受苦的土地带来和平的事实。记住，他一直在向京都周围的饥民供应粮食。
who lived around Kyoto. And now again, he can say, well, I am bringing you peace where neither the Tyra nor my cousin had been able to bring peace. But there's also another factor which Yorotomo very much wants to keep quiet. And this is the fact that anything which damages the prestige of Kyoto and its standing as the undisputed capital of Japan is only playing into his hands. Because Yorotomo, exceptionally, he's the first samurai lord to feel this. he has no loyalty to Kyoto. He hadn't lived there since he was 12.
现在他再次可以说，好吧，我给你们带来了和平，而平氏和我的表亲都没能带来和平。但还有一个因素，赖朝非常想保持低调。这就是任何损害京都声望及其作为日本无可争议的首都地位的事情，都只会对他有利。因为赖朝，非常特别地，他是第一个有这种感觉的武士领主。他没有对京都的忠诚。他从12岁起就没在那里住过。
And his base is Kamakura. His fiefdom is Kanto. His recruiting grounds are the eastern half of Honshu. He recognizes that if he is going to rule Japan, it is pointless for him to do it from Kyoto. He has to do it from the east, which had always been the traditional stronghold of the Minamoto. And this, I think, is the measure of how clear-sighted he is,
他的基地是镰仓。他的封地是关东。他的征兵地是本州岛的东半部。他认识到，如果他要统治日本，从京都统治是毫无意义的。他必须从东方统治，那里一直是源氏的传统据点。我认为，这就是他头脑清醒的衡量标准，
how unsentimental, how innovative, because this again is a completely revolutionary development. The idea that Japan might not be ruled from Kyoto, that it might be ruled from Kanto instead. It's impossible for most people even to contemplate it. Yet Yoritomo, it's this kind of plan that he has fully formed in his mind. So he is fully on for sending an armed expedition against Kiyos. and hopefully sees in control of Kyoto and effectively kind of bringing it into the Empire of the East. But he's not planning to lead this campaign himself. He wants to fight fire with fire. And so he entrusts the war against Kiso to a second young Minamoto general, who like Kiso is very dashing,
多么不感伤，多么创新，因为这又是一个完全革命性的发展。日本可能不是从京都统治，而是从关东统治的想法。大多数人甚至无法想象它。然而赖朝，这是他心中完全形成的计划。所以他完全支持派遣武装远征军对抗木曾义仲，
bold, charismatic. And this, of course, is Yoshitsunei. Yashitsunei has an elder brother, Minamoto No, Noriyori. Brilliant name for Nori Yori. So Noriori is sent to pacify Kiso's old stronghold, Shinano, you know, that kind of mountainous stronghold. And then to advance on Kyoto from the east. And Yoshitsunei is instructed to take the coastal road that leads along the south coast of Japan and then upwards towards Kyoto from the south. And so Kiso effectively is facing a two-pronged invasion. Noriorei from the east, Yoshitsune from the south.
并希望夺取京都的控制权，有效地将其纳入东方帝国。但他并不打算亲自领导这次战役。他想以毒攻毒。所以他把对木曾义仲的战争委托给第二位年轻的源氏将军，他像木曾义仲一样非常潇洒、大胆、有魅力。这当然就是义经。义经有一位兄长，源范赖。范赖这个名字真好。所以范赖被派去平定木曾义仲的旧据点信浓，你知道，那种多山的据点。然后从东方进军京都。义经被指示走沿着日本南海岸的沿海公路，然后从南方向上进军京都。所以木曾义仲实际上正面临两面夹击。范赖从东方，义经从南方。
And so he has no option but to divide his forces. And one army is sent to block the advance of Noriori from the east. And they reach the Setter Bridge, it's called, which crosses the southernmost tip of this huge lake, Lake Bewa. In fact, it's Japan's largest lake. And when they get there, they pull the bridge down so that the Minamoto forces hopefully won't be able to cross. And the second army is sent southwards to a place that we have already visited in this series. And this is Uji, which was the scene of the dramatic battle for the bridge that we described. in our previous episode.
所以他别无选择，只能分散兵力。一支军队被派去阻挡范赖从东方的进攻。他们到达了所谓的濑田桥，它横跨这个巨大湖泊——琵琶湖的最南端。事实上，它是日本最大的湖泊。当他们到达那里时，他们拆毁了桥，希望源氏军队无法通过。第二支军队被派往南方，去了一个我们在这个系列中已经访问过的地方。这就是宇治，也就是我们上一集中描述的戏剧性桥梁之战的现场。
And Uji Bridge, like Setta Bridge, is pulled down, as had happened in the first battle, the planks are pulled up and tossed into the sea. And also because they know that it's possible to ford the river, everyone knows this because the events of that previous battle had been so celebrated. They drive stakes into the riverbed at the fording points to try and stop cavalry from crossing. Meanwhile, Kiso himself waits in Kyoto where he will receive news from the two fronts and wherever the threat seems most pressing, he will then advance from Kyoto and go and bring reinforcements and try and hold the Minamoto attack wherever it's most pressing. So it's Uji that becomes the epicenter of the action, isn't it? It's Uji that Yotschitsune reaches that first.
宇治桥和濑田桥一样，被拆毁了，就像第一次战斗中发生的那样，木板被拆掉扔进了海里。而且因为他们知道可以涉水过河，每个人都知道这一点，因为那场前次战斗的事件非常出名。他们在涉水点把木桩打入河床，试图阻止骑兵通过。与此同时，木曾义仲本人在京都等待，他将收到来自两条战线的消息，无论威胁看起来最紧迫的地方，他就会从京都出发，带去增援，并试图在最紧迫的地方阻挡源氏的进攻。所以宇治成了行动的中心，不是吗？义经最先到达宇治。
and there's been a battle there four years before. So everyone knows, you know, there could be a repeat of it, and everyone knows that you can get across this river, you can forward the river, because that's what happened last time. And so there's this story, isn't there, the two samurai who are rushing, they're competing to be the first to cross this river. So these are two men in Yoshitsune's army.
四年前那里发生过一场战斗。所以每个人都知道，你知道，可能会重演，每个人都知道你可以过这条河，你可以涉水过河，因为上次就是那样发生的。所以有一个故事，不是吗，两个武士在冲锋，他们竞争成为第一个过河的人。所以这是义经军队里的两个人。
Is that right? Yeah. Well, tell us the story about the two samurai. It's a good story. So Yashitsunay's army is approaching the river Uji, the bridges down. There are these stakes in the crossing places. It's clearly going to be very, very dangerous to try and make a crossing. But it's a classic samurai thing.
是这样吗？是的。那么给我们讲讲那两个武士的故事。这是一个好故事。义经的军队正在接近宇治川，桥断了。过河的地方有木桩。试图过河显然会非常非常危险。但这是一种经典的武士行为。
In a situation like that, you prove your courage by being the first into the fray. And there are these two samurai who are determined to be the first across. And one of these is a guy called Kajawara, and he finds this promontory that sticks out into the kind of the boiling currents of the river Uji. And so he makes for that. And there is a second samurai, Sasaki, who sees him do it and follows him. And he's galloping behind Kajawara. And he calls out to him, of all the rivers here in the west, this is the biggest. Your girth looks loose, better tighten it.
在这种情况下，你通过成为第一个冲入战场的人来证明你的勇气。有两个武士决心成为第一个过河的人。其中一个是叫梶原的人，他找到了一个伸入宇治川汹涌水流中的岬角。所以他朝那个方向前进。有第二个武士，佐佐木，看到他这样做并跟随他。他在梶原身后飞奔。他对他喊道：“在西方的所有河流中，这是最大的。你的肚带看起来松了，最好勒紧它。”
And so Kajewara leans down from his saddle to cinch the girth tighter. And as he does so, Sasaki speeds past him, shouting, loser, plunges into the river. and begins making for the far bank. And Kajawar is furious, of course. He's been tricked, follows him in and tries to pay Sasaki back in the same coin. So he calls that, look out, Sasaki, don't play the fool out of a desperate thirst for fame. There must be ropes stretched underwater. But Sasaki draws his sword, he slatters at the ropes, he cuts them through, he gallops up the far banks,
于是梶原从马鞍上俯身去勒紧肚带。就在他这样做的时候，佐佐木从他身边飞驰而过，喊道：“输家！”冲进了河里，开始向对岸前进。梶原当然很愤怒。他被骗了，跟着他跳进去，试图以同样的方式报复佐佐木。所以他喊道：“小心，佐佐木，别为了出名的渴望而装傻。水下肯定有绳子。”但佐佐木拔出剑，他砍向绳子，把它们切断，他飞奔上对岸，
he rises in his stirrups, and he cries out in a stentorian voice, descended from Emperor Uda, nine generations in the past. Fourth son of Sasaki Hideyoshi, I am Sasaki Shiro Takatsuna, the first man across the Uji river. So it is so classic samurai. It's yelling out your forebears, announcing who you are, beating your chest, saying that you are the first into battle. Kajawara, I mean, he's very cross, but he is the second.
他在马镫上站起来，用洪亮的声音喊道：“宇多天皇九代后裔，佐佐木秀义第四子，我是佐佐木四郎高纲，第一个过宇治川的人。”这真是太经典的武士了。大声喊出你的祖先，宣布你是谁，拍着胸脯，说你是第一个投入战斗的人。梶原，我的意思是，他非常生气，但他也是第二个。
He manages to make it to the far bank as well. and their example inspires, first of all, hundreds of horsemen, then thousands to follow across the river. Lots of them are swept away, but lots of them make it across. They overwhelm the defenders. Uji is taken and the road to Kyoto lies open. It's exciting. And Yoshitsune takes this road, doesn't he? Because he is in a hurry.
他也成功到达了对岸，他们的榜样首先激励了数百名骑兵，然后是数千人跟随过河。他们中很多人被冲走了，但很多人成功过河。他们压倒了守军。宇治被占领，通往京都的道路敞开了。这很令人兴奋。义经走了这条路，不是吗？因为他很着急。
He wants to get there quickly because he wants to find Gosurikawa and he wants to get the legitimacy that the cloistered emperor can give him. Because Kiso, if he was smart, is going to kill this bloke. And Yoshitsune wants to get there first. Yes. So he goes herring up the road from Uji to Kyoto. And he arrives at the palace where Gosherakawa was under house arrest. And Yoshisunay dismounts. He knocks.
他想尽快到达那里，因为他想找到后白河，他想获得法皇能给他的合法性。因为木曾义仲，如果他聪明的话，会杀了这个家伙。而义经想先到那里。是的。所以他从宇治飞奔到京都。他到达了后白河被软禁的宫殿。义经下马。他敲门。
He announces himself in a ringing voice. I'm sure there's lots of stuff about his great ancestry and all that kind of thing. And he finds that he has arrived in time. Gosherakawa is still alive. And understandably, he greets the arrival of your Shitsunei with enormous relief and gratitude. You know, he's safe, he's got rid of this awful kind of bumpkin. He is under the protection of Yoritomo and his dashing younger brother, Yoshitsunei. Craigie, but we don't know what's happened to Kiso, do we?
他用响亮的声音宣布了自己的身份。我相信有很多关于他伟大血统之类的事情。他发现他及时赶到了。后白河还活着。理所当然地，他以巨大的宽慰和感激之情迎接了义经的到来。你知道，他安全了，他摆脱了这个可怕的乡巴佬。他在赖朝和他潇洒的弟弟义经的保护之下。天哪，但我们不知道木曾义仲发生了什么，对吧？
So what's happened to him and what is he planning? Well, we will be finding out in the final episode of this epic series in which the great Civil War of the Samurai will reach its blood-soaked and terrifying climax. And not only that, Tom, but we'll be meeting history's most famous female samurai. So it'd be nice to get a woman onto the show. That'll be exciting. There will be a spectacular mass suicide.
所以他发生了什么事，他计划做什么？嗯，我们将在这一史诗系列的最后一集中找到答案，武士的大内战将达到其血腥而恐怖的高潮。不仅如此，汤姆，我们还将见到历史上最著名的女武士。所以让一位女性上节目会很不错。那会很令人兴奋。将会有一场壮观的集体自杀。
We shall finally be encountering, you know, something that, again, sadly lacking from this series, which has been samurai crabs. And we will be continuing the swashbuckling story of the hero of this story, who is, of course, Yoshitsune. So if there are any members of our own Samurai Brotherhood out there, the members of the Rest Is History Club, you can hear that episode right away. And of course, you'll also be getting all the fantastic content in the special extended newsletter.
我们将最终遇到，你知道，这个系列中遗憾地缺乏的东西，那就是武士螃蟹。我们将继续这个故事的英雄的侠义故事，他当然就是义经。所以如果我们的武士兄弟会中有任何成员，也就是“历史就是这样”俱乐部的成员，你们可以马上听到那一集。当然，你们也会在特别扩展的时事通讯中获得所有精彩的内容。
If you would like to join the Rest Is History Club and get the host of unbelievable benefits that come with it, then you merely need to go to the rest is history.com. And on that note, Tom, aligato, guzamas, and sayonara, everybody. Bye-bye. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
如果你想加入“历史就是这样”俱乐部并获得随之而来的大量令人难以置信的好处，那么你只需要去therestishistory.com。说到这里，汤姆，阿里嘎多，古扎伊马斯，再见，大家。拜拜。这一集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。